we've only watched one episode of
Chicago Med in the past but there's some
extreme episodes we're about to watch
huge thanks to era for sponsoring this
video let's get started
you concur atrial Central defect but you
feel it's an emergency well the
patient's already neces atrial septal
defect is a defect within the upper two
chambers of the heart remember the heart
is made up of four chambers ventricles
on the bottom Atrium on the top and if
there's a defect in the wall that
separates the two atria that's called an
ASD why am I looking at that camera I'm
looking at the wrong camera the whole
time if you have circulation returning a
clot back into the right side of the
heart it can then instead of shooting
into the lungs which obviously would be
a problem be a pulmonary embolism it
could go from the right Atria to the
left Atria and then from the left Atria
go into the left ventricle and get shot
out into the systemic portion of the
blood flow instead of the lung so it
bypasses the lungs and ends up in the
brain causing a stroke a blockage and
that's obviously incredibly detrimental
this is Mr from the Chinese Embassy Mr
Woodfield the director of the Chicago
Zoo doctor and the chief veteran why are
there
a zoo
you're patient
is
a gorilla meets zulin a panda they
literally are just making sure you up as
they go now so this was your idea Dr
Choi volunteers at the zoo okay that's
great but you know what is even more
interesting when a real patient actually
a real patient when a human patient
needs surgery and the doctor is busy
with the panda good luck explaining it
to the patient's family you see we know
your husband's heart problems
complicated but Panda he's a panda
you're a panda
see Miss Cheney your husband's heart
problems complicating that's an Eminem
lyric well that's fine but I'm not a
veterinarian she needs a cardiothoracic
surgeon
you've done this procedure many times no
he has not on it it's a different
species they didn't even give him like
something similar like is a panda even
remotely similar to a human
I guess I would have to
take her up to the cath lab and
close the defect with a balloon this is
done in humans a cat lab is a
catheterization lab it's where you go
from peripheral blood vessels either in
the arms or in the femoral area and you
gauge up a wire you gauge a catheter
which is basically like a little mini
hose over a wire and that catheter can
have some tools on it like a balloon you
can open up blood vessels you could put
stents in etc etc but to do this on an
animal and a species that you've never
done enough before I think that's just
ridiculous are we sure that we're all
comfortable spending our time and the
hospital's resources to save an animal
Dr Rhodes
zoos rent pandas from the Chinese
government for a million dollars a year
why because people love pandas
how is that an explanation if we save
this one it's a public relations coup
for this Hospital one which will lead to
much needed donations to save human
lives I had a struggle with my Hospital
getting behind the public relations of
supporting a doctor who's doing well on
social media and this hospital is
willing to support operating on a panda
for a PR story I've learned that there
are less than 2 000 pandas left in the
world so get a panda surgeon not even a
vet don't go to the vet that treats cats
and dogs go to the vet that operates on
hearts of pandas
secure a little posterior
how's it looking floral the Flora is
basically a real-time uh radiologic
device that allows you to see certain
blood vessels especially if you're in
injecting dye hold on how are we spiking
damn I can't continue if she says
tachycardic how do you know what is
tachycardic even for a panda like if you
ask me right now what is a fast heart
rate for a panda I'm making it up if I
tell you give her six milligrams of
adenosine on its way they're going to
stop the Panda's heart no pulse Hearts
arrested yeah that's what it's supposed
to do for humans
she's gonna come back right
and stew
the first time that I've given adenosine
to a panda
okay I don't know why I'm entertained by
this
what a pulse see this story would become
cooler if they just started having the
panda go crazy and turn into a
superhuman because they gave it like
atropine and atropine side effect on
pandas it makes them like really strong
and resistant to sedating agents that
would be cool she has an infusion around
the heart yeah low pressure bleed
damn I must have nicked the right atrial
appendage during the occlusion basically
what they're saying is the pandas
bleeding into the why do I know about
panda heart anatomy I'm assuming that
it's similar to the human heart there's
a pericardium that covers the heart it's
the lining that covers the organ and if
you have a slow bleed it can leak into
that area which actually becomes
problematic because if it leaks long
enough you can have cardiac tamponade
where the heart can't even expand fully
and just a pressure essentially chokes
the heart out we've got to relieve the
pressure and we shouldn't open around no
can't risk the blood loss we're gonna do
a pericardiocentesis okay I'll needle
her put in a drain and hopefully the
bleed will stop on its own give me the
paravat kit hurry back
see I could be a panda doctor too blood
has stopped draining BP and heart rate
of normalized we've dialed back on the
sedation see how she'll responds how she
responds she's gonna wake up and kill
all of you pandas are ruthless
she's coming around
all right the writers have to be on
strike when this episode was written
back to the show in just a second but
first I want to talk to you about air up
scented water that has made my hydration
fun and easy it's actually pretty cool
take a look an era bottle turns everyday
water into a delicious drink thanks to
their scent pods the Pod releases a
scent that adds flavor to your water all
without any sugar calories or additive
junk personally I like the blueberry
flavor as well as how clutch it's been
when I'm flying I recently went out to
LA to record a bunch of podcast episodes
and was so happy I could bring my air up
bottle through security fill it up at a
water fountain and stay hydrated on my
cross-country flight without any added
stress or add a duty-free shop costs
look if you ever flown and you know how
dry the recycled air can get but with
air up I'm enjoying the process of
staying hydrated throughout my entire
flight which helps keep my mucous
membranes moist and my skin feeling soft
so visit the link in my description use
code Dr Mike remember doctor is spelled
out and has a space to get 15 off your
order and smell the delicious water all
right let's get back to the video good
morning I'm Dr Choi you must be Dennis
the one and only and uh this is my
girlfriend and partner Aviva say hi to
Dr Choy you guys we don't allow
recording in hospitals like this mostly
because it also records other patients
in the area and that's HIPAA we're live
in front of 800 000 and people what's
you'rethejudge.com am I taking a seat so
I can examine you I don't know can I
take a seat
I'm not following not you Dr Troy he's
talking to our followers
they're voting
[Music]
sorry dude okay that's not good because
a if you're trying to do a proper
abdominal exam the abdominal muscles are
going to be tightened up because a
person's standing therefore you're not
going to be able to palpate the organs
properly so it's in the name you are the
judge.com
our followers vote on all of Dennis's
decisions look if you won't let me treat
you properly you should see another
doctor well I don't mean any disrespect
doc please don't send me back to the
waiting room my stomach is killing me
see like this is all illegal because
you're filming other patients
it's definitely food poisoning and they
may meet a ton of discount Sushi last
night ow you don't perform abdominal
exam
like you're giving a low five to someone
behind their back your warm in your
belly is obviously tender I'd like to
get a CT scan to relying anything
serious I'll be back I will say that is
really accurate a lot of VR doctors are
like oh you're warm and your belly's a
little sore here's a CT scan I'm like
can we like investigate a little bit
more maybe do some special tests so you
didn't have food poisoning you have
appendicitis I told you guys
can get you up to an operating room to
remove it before it bursts at moo
Butter's asking is there an alternative
to surgery yeah you can give IV
antibiotics but depending on how bad it
is waiting could be bad or it could be
okay in some cases it can be managed
with antibiotics but surgery is the
standard surgery is a no-go
it's a serious medical decision so they
can they be held liable for murder they
make it for you if your appendix
ruptures it's a good chance you'll die
I'm sorry the decisions made we're going
with the antibiotics Doris or the one
grand theft track Stone in 500
milligrams fragile for my patient in
four for most intra-abdominal infections
we go ciproflagel not Ceftriaxone Flagyl
I wonder why he did self-traction toys
show me your websites pretty pretty
interesting stuff
his name tag legit says chief of
Psychiatry I'm gonna get thrown in the
Looney Bin if y'all keep
punking with these votes so Dr Choi and
I just want to make sure you understand
that by opting out of the surgery that
you are putting your life in danger this
is the team trying to understand if he's
capable of giving consent to see if he
understands consequences of actions what
he's saying no to what he's saying yes
to and if someone cannot give consent
because they're out of the right state
of mind you can have someone recommend
treatments for them either a family
member or the doctor in charge he
clearly understands the decision he's
making yeah but he's not making the
decision true but he's willingly
allowing other people to do that for him
he's denied surgery to boost his online
following how can we say he doesn't pose
a risk to him just because he's Reckless
doesn't mean he's suicidal it's an
acceptable level of risk uh patient
autonomy that's it if the antibodies
don't take we'll just watch them die no
if he gets really sick maybe he could
change his mind and then go for surgery
it won't be a better surgery impact
surgery that is more emergent actually
is much more dangerous which is why in
some cases if the appendicitis is quite
mild we treat with the IV antibiotics to
calm down information wise and then do
an elective appendectomy what's
happening to him ultrasound I'm gonna
guess it perforated your appendix is
nearly perforated we need to get you
into surgery now babe it won't take long
until your appendix burst when that
happens it may be too late to save you
who kept saying you should put him on a
medicine called Cialis Cialis is an
erection medication actually Cialis is
also used for BPH large prostate what
are we doing up here I figured out how
we can double your followers in an
instant I don't think you get how this
works
it took us over a year to get to a
million I think I know exactly how this
works he's going to say should we throw
him off the ledge and they vote and they
say yes and then he doesn't want to do
it and then they say oh so you want the
surgery slow down Egghead I want you to
ask your followers a very simple
question
should you jump off this roof right now
oh because if he says yes that he's
suicidal then they can schedule Aid him
or whatever is called and keep him and
like do the medical treatment he said
your father was love you right they
didn't want to see anything bad happen
to Dennis you had nothing to worry about
[Music]
strategies
he's suicidal we have to treat him
the appendectomy went well hey the
surgeon expects me to make a full
recovery most appendectomies are done
laparoscopically which means they're
minimally invasive so they kind of put a
few small holes inside your body in
order to put the tools in that they need
including a camera and then they just
either glue up or sew up the holes and
you're good to go we do have you sign a
release so when you're going for surgery
that it may become open depending on if
there's a complication at which point we
do need to create a surgical opening
okay Shep I'm Dr Choi what brings you in
today about six weeks ago I was
diagnosed with GBM it's a terminal brain
cancer glioblastoma multiforming GBM is
a very fast growing and it's one of the
more common brain Cancers and what's
unfortunate about it is the prognosis is
very poor it actually stems from the
specific cells in in your brain called
astrocytes and these are nerve
supporting cells it can cause problems
mostly due to Mass Effect because it
starts putting on pressure on different
areas of your brain actually even
pulling away blood circulation and
bringing circulation to itself surge
radiation chemo all options obviously
depending where it is in your brain but
even if you do treat it the recurrence
rate is quite High the phone call I just
made was to a company called CCI they're
going to preserve me until a cure can be
found for my condition they're on their
way here now to freeze you it's called
vitrification but yeah you understand
you have to be declared dead first the
cocktail I've been drinking contains
amitriptyline lorazepam and 200
milligrams of amphetamines when she put
me to sleep in a little over an hour and
rest my heart sufficiently for you to
declare me dead in about five why did he
smell it as if any of those things have
a scent to them come here stop
your your societal you cannot refuse
have you had a chance to review Mr
Shepard's medical records Sam yeah his
terminal I mean I could go in and do a
resection and aggressively radiate but
it'd buy them 12 to 15 months tops so he
should be on hospice where are we with
cryonics Sam I mean is it possible to
freeze the brain no yeah sort of but
that's the easy part hard part's thawing
it out again and having it still work
and exactly what they are testing
actually right now with NASA right now
one of the biggest problems when you
send astronauts to space is that they
require room to move extra nutrients
because they're awake and moving around
but if you can cause them essentially to
hibernate for like 14 days that might
make it easier on them less expensive
less room on the space shuttle and
therefore make it more reasonable to
send astronauts into space the way
they're doing this is by trying to
create a hibernation process by rapidly
cooling people's bodies we do something
like this actually in a medical Arena
where someone has a cardiac arrest and
their heart stops we actually do
therapeutic cooling of a patient in
order to decrease that metabolic demand
therefore buying them time and
potentially deep increasing damage from
their Cardiac Arrest or their heart
failing and not being able to circulate
blood the hospital across the street
could cure me
wouldn't you feel ethically compelled to
send me there for treatment I would
well that's what I'm doing
sending myself to a better Hospital
only the hospital I'm going to is in the
future finding somebody doesn't have the
capacity to make an informed decision
that means it's a high hurdle he's
committing suicide he's a danger to
himself by definition just put him on a
cycle yeah but if you follow his logic
he's he's not committing suicide why are
you following a person who's trying to
commit suicide logic with the amount of
medicines he took there's no way he's
sitting up and talking and being normal
like he's just taking way too many
psychoactive substances to be calm and
fine and normal and rational just not
realistic and with strong support my
wife and I decided we're going to honor
our son's wishes this way maybe someday
we'll get our son back
they probably just said what device
looks cool and they threw it on that
literally looks like that device that
does chest compressions for you I forgot
what it's called Mr Patrick
I assure you we did everything we could
she couldn't breathe
do you know what it's like
fields
there's a toxic spill Evacuate the Ed
now come on orange everyone right now so
in hospitals we have different color
codes for different situations for
example code blue means someone's heart
stop code red usually means fire code
black terrorist emergency each hospital
kind of has their own and on the back of
our ID badges we actually have all the
codes written in case we forget so
they're always handy
I repeat toxic exposure I don't know why
they don't all put on n95 respirators
because we generally have those and
those don't allow particles in for most
substances that could be harmful what
are you doing
this room has positive pressure
ventilation they're safe as long as we
stay in here that's true we actually use
a lot of those rooms with covet
pressure's dropping Derek are you
feeling dizzy a little what does that
mean that means you're still bleeding oh
no tearing your spleen isn't clotting
like I'd hoped a tear in the spleen is
really problematic because it can cause
a lot of bleeding and if you lose your
spleen that puts you at a really high
risk for certain infections specifically
bacterial infections with encapsulated
bacteria that's why when someone is
about to go for a splenectomy or spleen
removal generally before we try to get
them vaccinated if not if it's an
emergency we do it after we even have a
strong protocol in place for individuals
who are considered high risk to take
antibiotics daily as a preventive or to
make sure that everyone who doesn't have
a spleen has antibiotics at the ready so
if they show signs of an infection a
fever Etc they just take that first dose
of the antibiotic and then go right away
to the ER you can remove the spleen we
can't open them up he'll lose too much
blood and we don't have any to give them
I'm a universal donor that's insane the
surgery will take too long unless you
have a better idea I suggest you stop
making excuses and get started also you
want to test her and make sure she
doesn't have any communicable diseases
how does she know she does it I mean she
might have gotten tested a month ago but
maybe now she has something so like it's
ridiculous Stay With Me and
Ava hey Ava oh yeah take off the mask
while he's still open and cough inside
his wound now that he doesn't have a
spleen that's gonna go well sir did we
do it
yeah and now I'm getting him even more
sick
the spleen might be some people's
favorite organ but check out my favorite
organ as well as some of your favorite
social media docs click here to check
that out and again huge thanks to Arab
for sponsoring this video as always stay
happy and healthy
thank you
foreign